Tanner laver essoré sculpter modelé tous
ces gestes sont comme des rituels pour
Régis de Zara ce taxidermiste du lundi
au vendredi s'active dans son petit
atelier a donné une apparence de vie aux
animaux que ses clients lui apportent un
défi que Monsieur de Isara relève depuis
plus de 20 ans animé toujours de la même
passion d'enfant
vous savez comme beaucoup de gamins la
campagne on a une fronde on a
éventuellement une carabine à air
comprimé et puis
un jour j'avais trouvé un ce qu'on
appelle un petit piaf quoi et puis j'ai
voulu le conserver puis j'ai un peu
bricolé je l'ai naturalisé j'avais 10
ans et demi 10 ans 10 ans et demi quoi
monsieur de Isara fait partie des rares
taxidermistes sur les 300 en activité en
France à vivre de sa passion plus qu'un
art ou un passe-temps c'est un véritable
mode de vie ce qui ne l'empêche pas de
gérer sa petite entreprise d'artistes
animalier avec un certain sens de
l'économie
[Musique]
tout artisan doit être bricoleur s'ils
gagnent pas bricoleur c'est pas la peine
il peut mettre sous la porte parce que
bon c'est un et justement c'est ça ça se
vend dans le commerce spécial pour taxi
hermiste bon ça vaut autant puis après
il y a encore de choses qui vont et qui
va le temps etc bon bah c'est bon pour
pour des gens qui qui sont pas bricoleur
mais quand on est bricoleur bon ben on
arrive à faire tout soi-même et puis on
arrive à s'en sortir
c'est un métier où il faut savoir un peu
tout faire de la sculpture de la
chirurgie la chimie la chimie et tout
tout tout
et puis aussi en même temps
être débrouillard parce que je vois je
vois sur les catalogues spécialisés on
achète des moulages préfabriqués
on remet la peau par dessus bonbon on va
terminer il y a pas de recherche moi ce
qui m'intéresse c'est la difficulté et
puis la recherche
la recherche de quoi
la recherche de l'expression à donner à
l'animal
c'est un métier un peu entre guillemets
pas morbide mais enfin on manipule quand
même des cadavres au départ et vous vous
avez un boucher un boucher lui en fait
il découpe de la découpe de la viande et
puis les gens mangent des cadavres tous
les jours bon là
c'est un métier qui qui retransmet la
vie je dis que c'est un beau métier
vous avez une idée de comment vous
voulez le faire alors moi j'ai déjà un
siffleur donc mon siffleur est dans ce
sens là dans ce sens là je vois le
souchet soit dans l'autre sens ouais
d'accord
Régis de izara les animaux qu'il observe
sur lesquels il se documentent pour
toujours retrouver l'expression de vie
et les clients attendront 10 mois
environ pour récupérer le tableau final
et puis le pigeon vert ça vous plaît
c'est un souvenir surtout une décoration
en même temps bon enfin faut pas en
avoir trop non plus c'est après les
dames sont pas trop contentes il faut
nettoyer quoi surtout ça bon ça c'est
pour faire si vous voulez mettre
dans une table de salon tout en vert
avec le sable j'ai ramené du riz du
Sénégal pour planter dans une planche
Boisse pour les mettre en milieu naturel
ça va être vraiment posé ça va pas être
des choses accrochées chasseur
collectionneur ou simple amateur
certains clients confient aussi parfois
leurs animaux de compagnie et c'est à
chaque fois un cas de conscience pour le
naturaliste
c'est toujours jusqu'à l'heure j'ai
toujours toujours essayé de dissuader
les gens mais je suis jamais arrivé mais
c'est un chagrin énorme qui
n'arrive pas surmonter je pense un
animal de compagnie fait beaucoup plus
difficile et je ne l'ai je ne l'ai fait
que si les gens ont des photos qui n'ont
pas de photos je le fais pas parce que
moi cette animal de son vivant je l'ai
jamais connu et donc je n'arrive pas à
retransmettre les expressions de son
vivant
Eliott était un collet de 13 ans cher à
la famille de Monsieur colio et c'est
très naturellement qu'il y a un an cet
habitant de Duclair a fait naturalisé
son chien par Monsieur de Isara au
départ
[Musique]
il est magnifique une réalisation
superbe donc
il est considéré comme étant en ville
pratiquement beaucoup de personnes qui
le voient pensent que
les sages votre chien effectivement il
est sage
il est vraiment naturel
vous avez des périodes de commande
particulière des périodes pointes
comment le sanglier de canard de
l'ouverture de la chasse à la fermeture
ou là c'est le plein boom
et puis sinon après
ça sera au mois de mars avril
puis après bon ça se calme un peu quoi
ça me permet de prendre des vacances en
été quoi mais bon les congélateurs sont
plein
un peu magicien ou simple artiste Régis
de Isara A43 ans ne se lasse pas et sa
clientèle non plus et si le métier de
taxidermiste tente à disparaître faute
de formation il est encore fidèle au
poste toujours prêt à accomplir son
œuvre
[Musique]